huit postes de juges pour huit
nationalités les plus représentatives de
la discipline à chaque poste un juge
donc un assistant et une secrétaire
ici le poste français gil guyomard
annonce les figures du programme car à
aucun moment le juge principal ne doit
quitter l'avion des yeux un peu comme au
patinage artistique une boucle est avec
1,2 me pose en montée
2011au la pause après tirer pour quatre
facettes en eau
ensuite c'est le retour dans leurs cales
vers le bas avec un tour aicart deux
vrilles domine aig alternait ce même
principe à savoir que pour un programme
qui composait de plusieurs figures nous
notons séparément chaque figure plus
c'est une originalité par rapport au
patinage on juge le positionnement du
programme dans l'ensemble du back savoir
s'il est répartie symétriquement pas
contre la grosse différence par rapport
au patinage c'est qu'après il ya un
traitement informatique des t notes qui
vise à éliminer les notes à beyrouth les
figures se déroule dans ce que l'on
appelle la boxe à kilomètres cubes
les pilotes lui a des repères au sol
alors le juge apprécie la qualité et la
précision de la figure comme ceux
français
dana courtois troisième juge mondial
depuis dix ans il est pilote instructeur
de voltige
il faut juger à la fois la trajectoire
c'est à dire la ligne il faut qu'elle
soit conforme soit horizontale soit
verticale soit à 45° montante ou
descendante et il faut que le taux les
rotations soit placée au milieu de ces
lignes donc on va juger à la fois la
direction de la ligne faut qu'elle soit
bien dans laxe toute déviation de 5° c
-1 point et les rotations c'est pareil
si il manque 5 degrés un tonneau ça sera
moins un point gamin à la fin de chaque
passage tout le monde rejoint le chef
juge qui fera une analyse sur ordinateur
des résultats